10 reconnue bien entendu louis gignac
oui bien sûr voilà je me permets de
m'immiscer ce soir dans la petite
lucarne
afin de lui avoir rappelé de quartz
rendu sur cette émission de gaudriole
alors habituellement c'est vous qui
vilipendaient les autres programmes oui
bien sûr c'est moi même louis gignac
fils de françois vidal célèbre aux
diplomates à ses heures perdues que vous
n'osiez honnête monsieur hanouna
monsieur hanouna d'accord très bien vous
devez le connaître mon célèbre père non
non non pas du tout oui bon et bien vous
n'avez pas de culture vous n'avez aucune
culture
je m'assieds à côté du livreur louis
médias donc il va nous faire un bilan de
cette première semaine ne touche pas à
mon poids je suis là pour vous assénez
de mes quatre vérités
ah oui vous l'entendez bien bien sûr
vous êtes prêts oui vous allez dire ce
que vous pensez de chacun d'eux voilà je
vous je vous conseillerais aussi dans
vos cases de profiter de mes conseils
david et et de d'ouvrir vos esgourdes
d'accord sympathique voulait démarrer
par qui je peux m'adresser au livreur
vous êtes bien moins de 10 - 10 oui une
personne qui gagne moins de 10000 euros
par mois ah oui largement tu peux
j'imagine déjà le portrait je vous
imagine avec votre famille en train de
déguster de délicieux sandwichs sodebo
acheter sur nère de brive la gaillarde
[Rires]
avec les routiers en marcel blanc tout
poilu a déclaré du cul attentes
c'est bien ça cependant raymond se
donner non c'est mon deuxième prénom
parce que vous n'êtes pas tout à fait le
pass le faciès de raymond domenech qu'on
va dire non pas du tout voilà déjà dans
le foot bon je vais vous appelez toufik
alors on y va pour cette petite et
évaluation oui géraldine pour moi c'est
un 10 sur 10 ha oui quelle femme de
caractère vous n'aimez rien et moi non
plus nous sommes en parfaite adéquation
alors vous avez de la chance je suis un
bon parti et je me suis émue rachel ou
merde oui alors non le plus intéressant
est ce que je vais dire c'est à dire que
si l'envié vous venez de me on va dire
de me tripatouiller la nouille
sachez que genève et regarde
inconvénient est que je serai prêt même
vous offrir ma virginité
c'est une bonne nouvelle ça a une
dignité c'est toujours excitant
ah oui géraldine maillet va exciter tout
est ce que le maître de cérémonie
monsieur hanouna peut se taire quelques
secondes d'abord de vos convives
ça ne vous dérange pas d'accord je
m'occuperai de vous à la fin je viens à
vous bernard pour moi c'est un 7 sur 10
mais pour bernard moi c'est pourquoi la
usl je vais alors nous nous connaissons
très bien
nous avons l'habitude de profiter sur le
yacht de papa s'appelle dans l'intimité
mon cher bernie alors la seule ombre au
tableau vient de votre bronzage factice
c'est à dire que je me dis qu'un vrai
plus de 10 ce doit normalement de passer
des vacances régulièrement aux maldives
pour entretenir son teint hâlé
là où vous mon cher bernie et bien vous
vous comportez comme on va dire un
ouvrier en manque de vacances il va se
faire dorer le coucher du soleil
je trouve je trouve pour ma part que ça
fait tache notable d'où le 7 sur 10 je
suis désolé isabelle marc à
pour moi c'est un 5 sur 10 et vous savez
que je vous affectionne et pour moi le
problème ne vient pas de vous mais de
votre moitié
comment votre fumier de mari faut-il
vous laisser cravacher du matin au soir
pour ramener le pain à la maison
[Rires]
monsieur hanouna a mis d'accord comment
peut-il encore se regarder dans une
glace et à chasser d'accord donc voilà
pour moi le problème c'est celui ci et
je vous garantis que si j'avais votre
mari en face de moi je le casting ray
comment où et la caméra joli casting
mais comment alain morini-bosc je te
casse taille je le casting alors hier
nous vous annoncions rené maleville
alors rené bon oui alors vous avez le
don de me divertir et de me rappeler que
j'ai la chance d'être bien né société
mais j'ai examiné votre profil là nous
sommes dans tpm peu ouvert à tous mais
vraiment à tous tous tôt cette année
dernière exception vous correspondez à
l'idée que je me fais des fanatiques de
football a les cheveux gras et un
franc-parler tout droit sorti du troquet
du coin c'est le football voilà c'est le
football c'est le football il est à
l'image du foot ban est erronée est ce
que vous avez quelque chose à lui dire
francs je lui trouve pas trop de talent
qu'elle dit par deux mois voilà d'accord
mais que quand tu parle de vous ah oui
mes propres adhérents riz à widnes je
suis mes propos dérangeants voulait
aller trouver un c'est un moins 10 sur
10 jamais mon avis je vais apprendre et
on voit que j'avais quand je donne mon
avis on s'est alors je sais qu'il reste
toute la rangée de gauche mais je
regarde rarement à gauche je laisse ça à
lionel jospin alors je vais maintenant
finir sur vous le savez le maître de
cérémonie monsieur hanouna
non non je ne reviendrai pas aux mains
ça marche
alors vous devez sans doute avoir un
compte en banque aseb bien garni nous le
savons nous vivons tous les deux assez
confortablement mais je tiens à vous
préciser que nous ne nous ressemblons
pas ah oui pourquoi moi disons que je
suis pour vous donner une image le pain
de campagne finement tranchées là où
vous vous êtes le pain que l'on donne
aux canards mais que les choses soient
claires nous n'avons pas élevé les
cochons ensemble
je ne suis pas fan de cette émission je
tiens à vous le dire mais
connaissez-vous maxime saada
bien sûr le patron de le directeur de
canal + frais voilà je vous présenterai
h et qu'à la moindre contrariété
moi je tiens ramona vous retournerez
manger des boulettes chez votre mère il
est excellent à paris
[Applaudissements]